et on passe maintenant à notre grand
d'invité d'honneur de la semaine
ça pourrait être toi mais ces jus et le
bim
la star qu'on appelle juliette cinoche
ici en france absolument absolument
juliette binoche rebond soir j'étais à
ses lectrices à avoir gagné un césar un
bafta un oscar et un prix
d'interprétation à cannes à venise et à
berlin il vous reste plus qu'à ligue des
champions et l'aude d'or
[Musique]
à lens car je
[Applaudissements]
l'oscar sécu pour le patient anglais
2001 et en fait il vous avez poussé à
bout dans une scène je vais pleurer en
fait c'est parce que c'est le dernier
moment avant de donner une note et
naziha au patient anglais et il y avait
de la musique avec bac tout le monde est
temps qu'il y avait des branches de
france gall
il y avait un silence sacré est
magnifique et en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que j'ai ouvert l'an poule pour
jouer et je l' ai tellement ouverte
qu'elle m'a ouvert les doigts donc il y
avait du sang est vrai fêté un peu
horrifiée parce qu'il avait peur que je
me fasse mal et en fait j'ai j'ai perdu
le contrôle et j'ai un peu pleuré et je
pense que j'ai l'oscar à cause de serre
après un accident tout bête c'est vite
arrivé sur le sol
alors qu'il faut dire
c'est que lauren bacall côté contre vous
pour les oscars où il avait gagné une
espèce de sentiment d'imposture oublié
lui lui donner le ska en fait vous
l'avez donné à votre fils qui a joué
avec le ska et peu à peu lors ses
écailles et tu vas peut assez rapidement
la plaie est en fait il suffit de
gratter un peu et laure devient tout
simplement s'est ainsi bien sa red bull
mais voilà ce n'est pas de l'or massif
ont fait non les [ __ ] ils ont changé
quand même
c'est pas parce qu'il peut pas garder un
oscar pelé donc on leur en va de bart un
autre ou des oscars ne m'a pas changé il
a changé le regard des eaux c'est vrai
ouais ouais t'as regardé votre regard
cataractes
j'en avais fait du bien c'est une star à
hollywood quand elle a pas de café
l'appelle directement au
téléphone
la loose alors juliette pour toutes les
jeunes actrices qui nous regardent et
qui pourraient se sentir écrasé par
votre filmographie et par vaux
récompense je me suis dit qu'il était
important de regarder vos débuts à
l'écran parce que ça peut donner
[Musique]
moi
je la prends prenez un chamallow entre
le pouce et l'index affleck voulons
poser délicatement sur la langue
est là étendez vous voilà
prolonger le plaisir est en écoute à
chemin vous prenez un autre chamallow et
pour commencer au moment où bon qu'au
bon fond
alors juillet quand on trees mercredi au
cinéma dans le film telle mère telle
fille de noémie saglio avec elle en
heure en compétition en fait en gros
faut le dire mais moi j'aime bien l'idée
que les gens quand ils ont envie d'aller
voir un film façon ils vont aller ces
comptes comédie donc quand même
complètement une comédie très girly qui
est la vôtre est complètement une
comédie hyper trash qui est la nôtre et
et ça l'est certainement bien meilleur
mais je
[Applaudissements]
sais que j'en suis à toi ils sont le 5
avril tu es tranquille
ils sont 5 avril je vais rester dans la
flagornerie vous jouez la mer ou la
fille
je suis en train de me suis en train de
me truquer les eaux
ap
et
alors le pitch le pic vous êtes une mère
qui vit aux crochets de sa fille qui est
enceinte et qui découvre qu'elle est
elle même enceinte à 50 ans après avoir
couché avec son ex mari alors vous êtes
donc une mer encore ado
envahissante et déjanté vous fait la
gueule quand on vous refuse quelque
chose vous rangez pas votre chambre vous
fumer de l'herbe vous baiser sans capote
alors votre fille camille cottin elle
c'est l'inversé les mariés salariés
organisé ça a rien à voir et le père
c'est lambert wilson que vous retrouvez
trente ans après rendez-nous de téchiné
c'est marrant à l'époque j'étais pas
bien connu mais là vous avez fait
connaissance ouais voilà parce que
j'étais assez fasciné par lui jeta
boroughs lui et donc j'ai pas osé lui
parler j'étais intimidé et là trente ans
après bon bah on a pu enfin parler
génial j'adore c'est vraiment drôle
alors vous dites germinales ça me fait
plaisir de revenir en arrière de vivre
ces moments
d'adolescentes que je n'ai jamais eu
c'est vrai pas un que vous habitiez dans
le
enfance de juliette binoche dans le loir
et cher à mondoubleau
c'est vrai oui c'est pas loin de
bordeaux mais bon ben
voilà chewing gum en tue comme moussavi
[ __ ]
comment tu connu ça toi mes grands
parents étaient des doigts aux ongles
aux italiens aux mobylettes
et donc en sortons de cette adolescence
vous êtes fait une permanente blonde bah
ouais on avait tout à l'heure avec les
chamallows tout ça même si c'est ma
première maintenant tu es blonde blonde
annonce way et finalement ce rôle là
dans le film de sa bio c'est un peu une
permanente blonde non à banon
non-croyants mr ouai bah les perruques
ça existe c'est une verrue
dans notre film à nous
[Musique]
et mon père aussi maman c'est
l'émotion
[Applaudissements]
est maintenant là
la question la plus importante juliette
comment ça va question romeo soit pas
mal d'accord alors vous avez déclaré mon
rêve serait de réussir une vraie vie de
couple pour l'instant je ne suis pas
tout à fait arrivée c'est à dire que si
j'avais qu'une personne n'y habite de
l'autre côté du monde mais c'est
compliqué mais les liteaux
dans le divan de marc olivier fogiel
vous avait révélé en avril 2016 je suis
revenu avec quelqu'un d'antan et c'est
carrément génial c'est ça ouais
bon je veux pas aller plus loin que
c'est ambitieux basé sur la discrétion
de sens à ce serait génial parce qu'elle
dit pas un ex elle dit quelqu'un d'antan
vous êtes vraiment dans le détail comme
ils s'appellent vous êtes vraiment une
actrice romantique à quelqu'un dans le
temps c'est beau bon ce qui
donne actuellement bas leinders acteurs
non non c'est pas le genre laurent du
clan mais je sais que c'est pas le genre
de la maison un avis je vais de ses
initiales pour les gens qui jouent mais
moi je vais juger j'ai rencontré le
compagnon de juliette à los angeles
avant oui mais alors là tout ballon cela
voilà dix derrière
si je peux me permettre il m'a dit que
mercredi là les voir gangstarr dames
c'est tout
juliette est ce que un jour un homme
vous a dit mais quelle lumière jaillit
par cette fenêtre voile à lorient et
juliette et le soleil
si shakespeare et ouais j'imagine bien
qu'à sa tête à mascouche et j'imagine
non c'est pas moi à tanger roméo juive
est ce qu'un homme vous a dit ça aussi
bien écrit j'ai pas sûr mais dans les
yeux tous se dit
julien je crois que le mieux maintenant
ce serait de faire une interview par
amour
[Musique]
julie albinos us que paramo vous seriez
prête à arrêter le cinéma ouais
et la chance peut-être
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous convertir à une autre religion
non non est-ce que paramore pourriez
quitter la france pour toujours et vous
exiler en syrie
chaud les paras mo/s qui peuvent
arbitrer
il sentirait très très mal ce que par
amour ou pourriez avoir recours à la
chirurgie esthétique
non
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
le mec il adore les rues basses à
prendre 20 kg
est-ce que par amour c'est unique au 15
évidemment tout ça le fait c'est de la
fiction vous seriez vous prête à vivre à
trois avec sa maîtresse hamas est
étonnant parce que moi j'ai une idée
d'un film comme ça à 3 way avec donc
c'est le sujet m'intéresse grandement et
je le sens
où j'ai fait du bruit c'est vrai ça vous
avez des cinq équipes du bruit
vous seriez pas te livre à trois avec sa
maîtresse
j'ai une copine qui vit avec deux hommes
et je pense que c'est vraiment moi c'est
en étant dans l'épreuve que on pourrait
que je pourrais le savoir mais sans être
en phase de l'épreuve espaces verts
alors toujours on est toujours là c'est
par amour amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à aller tous les soirs ne des
clubs échangistes n'ont carrément pas à
3 sur deux alors
non une fois par semaine une fois par
mois et même pas parents non à huy alors
ça vous n'êtes pas club échangiste allez
on pas tellement la maman aussi alors
est ce que vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle là à tous si tout
est transformé par l'amour c'est plus de
l' esclavage sexuel
et maintenant la question dite question
clotilde courau parce que tout il court
avait répondu oui est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sales ah oui alors oui
pas de problème pas de première
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu